good
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
was greeted by a grand reception as
German Chancellor Olaf scholz welcomed
him to Berlin with military honors
this is zelenski's first trip to the
country since Russia's invasion of
Ukraine and he will be returning home
with a big get Germany pledged nearly 3
billion euros for weapons and equipment
the largest military aid package since
the conflict began
Ukraine has our full support says Shoals
condemning the Russian invasion as an
imperialistic attack at the onset of the
war Berlin was reluctant to arm Ukraine
but has since become one of the biggest
suppliers of military hardware like
leopard tanks Germany has worked very
hard to overcome its image as a
militaristic aggressive country since
World War II but the Ukrainian president
did not walk away with everything he
wanted they would love to be getting
warplanes from Germany that's what
they're really asking for again
zelenski's Outreach to three European
powers Germany Italy and France comes as
Ukraine prepares for a widely
anticipated counter-offensive in bakmut
the big question is does Ukraine have
now the capacity to do what Russia no
longer has the capacity zelenski told
reporters in Germany Ukraine is almost
ready for victory but he faced questions
about conversations he may have had
behind closed doors according to the
Washington Post leaked intelligence
documents shows zelenski suggested
Ukraine conduct strikes in Russia
something zielinski dismissed saying
Ukraine does not have the time or
resources that has been kind of a red
line if Ukraine were to hit Russian
territories or perhaps then that would
put the war on a different level
zelenski insists
counter-offensive is about liberating
Russian occupied areas of Ukraine and
not attacking Russian territory tariya
Israel Global News Ottawa